hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series with the goal to try to
learn from people who've done a lot more
than us and by hanging around them a
little bit longer hopefully their
mindset ambitions dreams way of thinking
seeps into us a little bit more that
helped us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from Bruce Lee on staying motivated
mentor me Bruce and as always if Bruce
says something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
as a human being how can i express
myself totally inconvenient
[Music]
all type of knowledge ultimately means
self-knowledge
Lizzy is a real
to locate to wound ultimen Marshall
items honestly expressing yourself
every time you come back well
both
no one liked you better producer
I have no fear or underneath random
self-sufficient
and I should I find that when things I
have made up my mind and absolutely
is very difficult I mean it is easy for
me to put on a show and be cocky
flooding the cauchy-riemann don't feel
like pre-cool on all that I just make
all kinds of funny miss you I mean will
hang tomorrow I can show you some really
fancy art to express oneself honestly
lying to myself and to express myself
once that my friend is very hard to do
and you have to train you have to keep
your reflexes so that when you want it
it's there when you want to move you're
moving and when you move you're
determined to not taking one inch to not
anything less than that if I want to
punch it I'm gonna do it and I'm gonna
do it and so on so that is the type of
thing you have to train yourself into to
become one I said empty your mind be
formless shapeless like water now you
put water into a cup it becomes the cup
you put water into a bottle it becomes
the bottle you're putting a teapot it
becomes the teapot the water can flow or
it can crash be water my friend it's not
difficult to learn and speak the word
the hard thing the difficult thing it's
behind what is the meaning what fall on
the expression and feelings behind those
world
the successful ingredient in it was
because I was being Bruce Lee yourself
myself right you talk about the Chinese
boxing how does it differ from saying
our kind of boxing
well first we use the feet stand down we
use the elbow and use the thumbs you
name it man we use it all you have to
you see because I mean that is the
expression of the human body
I mean to everything I mean you know not
just a hand and when you're talking
about combat well I mean if it if it is
a sport now now you talk about something
else
you have regulations you have rules but
when you're talking about fighting as it
is always with no real fighter well done
baby you better train every part of your
body and when you do punch now I'm
leaving for a little bit hoping not to
hurt any camera angle I mean you gotta
put the whole hip into it and snap it
and get all your energy in there and
make this into a weapon you are not
ready I don't know like everyone else
you want to learn the way to win and
never gonna accept the way to lose to
accept defeat to learn to die is to be
liberated from it so when tomorrow comes
you must free you're ambitious mind and
learn the art of dying you still think
of yourself Chinese are you everything
yourself as North American you er you
know what I want to think of myself as a
human being because I mean I don't want
him sounds like you know as Confucius
say but under the sky under the heaven
man there is but one family it just so
happened man that people are different
thank you guys so much for watching I'd
love to know what did you think of this
video what was your favorite clip what
did you learn from this and you're going
to apply to your business or your life
please share your thoughts leave a
comment below and I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon